[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing a family
that you might know the Weasleys now the
Weasley family is quite large and
consists of Fred George Charlie
Molly Arthur Ginny bill Percy and of
course Ron obviously there are more
Weasley's but these are the main ones
that were introduced to in this series
we know and love the Weasley family for
both their quirks and their kindness to
Harry throughout the books and films
they really are good people who have
nothing but Harry's best interest in
mind
Molly Weasley takes Harry in like one of
her own without second guessing it at
all come Christmas time she's always got
a new jumper knitted for Harry I can
guarantee that but one thing that's hard
not to notice about them is their
lifestyle their clothes one's home and
attitude all sort of suggest that they
don't have much money in the
philosopher's stone Draco Malfoy even
makes a comment towards Ron which
suggests that the Weasley name is
synonymous with this sort of thing think
my name is funny do you well no need to
ask yours red hair and a hand-me-down
robe you must be a Weasley this is quite
an offside comment but he is technically
correct Ron was a Weasley and it was a
hand-me-down robe so what's the deal
with them Lucius Draco's father makes a
similar condescending comment in a
separate scene let's see red hair vacant
expressions tatty secondhand book you
must be the Weasleys so do they not have
any money or does it just appear that
way perhaps they're just really good
savers let's dive into this further
obviously the providers for the family
are the parents Molly and Arthur however
it just so happens that only Arthur
works and the Molly is a stay-at-home
mum this means that Arthur is the only
stream of income for the family Arthur
worked for the Ministry of Magic in
multiple roles at first he worked for
the misuse of muggle artifacts
department the primary function of this
department was to regulate the use of
magic on muggle
Jex and to try and keep you which items
away from muggles later on arthur was
promoted and assumed the role of head of
office for the detection and
confiscation of counterfeit defensive
spells and protective objects department
we aren't actually provided with
in-depth information on how much arthur
makes but it still seems like the
Weasleys have a bit of a hard time
getting by this is unusual because
Arthur in both of his roles is head of a
department why are the finances spread
so thin firstly in Arthur's first role
Cornelius fudge aka the Minister for
magic was still in charge it's well
known that Arthur and Cornelius did not
get along this inhibited his career
progression and it no doubt impacted his
salary it meant that he was never able
to get the raises or emotions that he
deserved it should come as no surprise
that as soon as Cornelius fudge was out
of office that Arthur got his promotion
however it wasn't until 1996 that fudge
was out of office which meant that for
the majority of his children's
adolescent lives he was stuck in his
former lower paying role he was stuck in
a dead-end job without much chance of
progression supporting a family of seven
children and a wife not only that but
all of these children attended a
Hogwarts
while Hogwarts is affordable it's not
that affordable and for one stream of
income to support all of this would be
very difficult
Hogwarts itself is free but the
materials required to attend the school
are not this means that Arthur would
have had to have bought ones books
brooms and all sorts for all seven of
his children on top of that he had to
pay for taxes bills insurance food
clothes robes and even fines are his
children incurred case in point the
flying for dangler incident it's
reported that it cost him fifty galleons
which given the implications actually
seems quite reasonable so basically he's
got a lot of children a lot of expenses
and a job that doesn't pay particularly
well this brings us to Molly
why didn't she work Molly Weasley was a
stay-at-home mum which when you have
seven children is of particular
importance while Arthur's working who's
going to take care of these children
it was pivotal that Molly assumed the
month of the role that she did so well
and there honestly wasn't a lot of
opportunity
to work this meant they just had to keep
going the way that they were fortunately
for the Weasley family it was never
about the money or keeping up
appearances it was about love friendship
and union while the Malfoy family had a
lot of generational wealth it didn't
make them happy money doesn't buy
happiness where Molly couldn't afford to
buy her children fancy brooms and
presents she instead knitted them
personalized jumpers with nothing but
wool and love while the Weasley children
was sometimes embarrassed and would
scoff at their circumstances I'm sure
that at the end of the day they take
their parents over anyone elses and
that's it for the video if you guys
enjoyed it please hit the like button
did I miss anything if so please let me
know down in the comment section below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]